-Welcome, guys.
-Thank you.
-I'm so happy to have you here.
I want to congratulate you
on the show.
But first, Nafessa,
you are from Philadelphia.
-I am born and raised in Philly,
and I'm celebrating all year.
-Oh, that's fantastic.
You have to take the whole year.
But you were not in Philadelphia
last night, correct?
-I wasn't. I was here.
-Yeah.
-I was, like, getting ready
for you today.
-Well, thank you for doing that.
-I had to have my fitting
and watch the Super Bowl
at the same time.
But it was good. We won.
I'm good.
-That's great.
And I would feel bad,
but I have to be honest,
when you schedule something,
you would never think,
"Well, that will be the day
the Eagles win the Super Bowl."
Never happened.
-No. No.
You can't plan that.
You can't predict it.
-Exactly.
Well, congratulations.
-Thank you.
-The show is already
incredibly popular.
What is it
about the show that you feel
viewers are connecting with
so early in its run?
-Well, I feel like the show,
even though it is about
a superhero
and a superhero family,
it's very rooted in reality.
Like, when it comes
to a superhero like Superman,
it's very fantastical,
and you don't feel
like you can walk outside
and be like, "Ooh,
it's a bird, it's a plane."
You know what I'm saying?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But with "Black Lightning,"
you feel like
you could see him
walking down the street.
Like, "Oh, there's our
neighborhood hero."
-Yeah, I think it's very
relatable, like she said.
He's a guy in your neighborhood.
He's the father figure
that you want within
the community,
which makes it pretty authentic
and relatable.
-And it does use actual --
I mean, it uses racism,
it uses gun violence.
Was that something
that drew it to --
I mean, again, I assume
when you first get a script
and you hear
it's about a comic book hero,
you might not expect
those things to be in there.
Were you excited when they were?
-We were really, really
into the script when we read it.
The female characters
are so strong
and powerful, confident,
just boldly walking
in who they are.
And, you know, those are the
kinds of roles that you want --
roles that are going to empower
and inspire.
And the Akils, they have done
such a great job
of bringing that authenticity
to it.
-Yeah, I love the fact the show
really tackles real issues.
And The CW lets us
be unapologetically black.
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
-That's good.
That's a good thing to be.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, you know what I'm saying?
[ Snaps fingers ]
-Snap, snap, snap.
-So, have you had --
have you had
great reactions from fans yet?
Is there one that stands out?
-Oh, yes.
We've had really great
fan reactions.
I always love
the little kids that come up.
And they're like,
"For Halloween,
I want to be Black Lightning."
Like, those are my favorites.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, and I think for me,
being the first black
lesbian superhero...
-Yeah.
-...you know,
I'm getting a lot of
just outpour of love
and support of, you know,
"Thank you for representing us.
It took a while
for us to see ourselves."
And I think representation
is really important,
and we all need to be able
to turn on the television,
see ourselves,
and be able to relate
to the characters
that we're watching.
So, super honored to,
you know, be that voice.
-And it's true,
I was not just --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Aww. Thank you.
-It feels like not just
black lesbian superheroes.
There haven't been many
black lesbians on television.
That must -- Did you feel
a responsibility to that,
or is it more like the freedom
of, "Oh, I get to do this thing
that not a lot of people have
seen and been able relate to"?
-You know, yeah,
I'm just really honored
to give my voice over
and more so proud.
You know?
And hopefully this show,
or my character in particular,
will be the first
of many black lesbians on film.
-That's fantastic.
-Thank you.
-And you had a background --
You did some criminal justice
stuff in Philadelphia, as well.
-I did.
I interned at the D.A.'s office
in the homicide unit.
-Go ahead, girl!
-Oh, my goodness.
[ Laughs ]
-Yeah, so I thought I wanted
to be a lawyer,
and then I told my mom,
"Mom, I'm just gonna
play one on TV.
That's -- That's the best
I can do for you."
-That's right.
-The things that I saw
within, you know,
the criminal justice system
are very parallel to the things
that we're touching on,
the topics within the show.
So kudos to that experience,
I guess.
I guess a degree wasn't,
you know, a bad idea.
-Yeah.
So you have
a little background there.
I'm guessing neither of you have
actual superhero backgrounds.
So when it comes to stunts,
how is your stunt work?
And are you getting to do
some stunt work?
-Yeah, I do a little bit
of butt kicking.
My powers actually come
after hers.
-Okay, gotcha, so --
-So I've been in stunt training
since July, and it's been fun.
I've been pretty athletic
and active throughout my life,
so it's just cool
to keep that going.
And I do as much
as my stunts as possible,
but my stunt double, Natasha,
she is really, really dope,
and we have a lot of fun.
So I can't wait for you guys
to see Thunder develop
and really start kicking butt.
We're just getting started.
-Oh, that's very exciting.
And I've heard that
what you lack in stunts,
you make up for -- you do
a lot of running on set.
-Oh, yes.
-While she has a really amazing
workout routine,
my workout routine
is running from craft services
back to the set.
-Okay, gotcha.
-You know what I'm saying?
-So you run to get snacks.
-Exactly.
-And then
they're looking for you,
and you have to run back.
-And they really try
to mess with me sometimes
because they put craft services
on a different stage.
-Oh, wow.
-Yes. Then when we're filming,
I'll be like,
"It's okay,
I'ma get my snacks either way."
-Whenever they yell cut
and you're looking for China,
crafty is where she's at.
-And do you have
a favorite snack?
What do you --
-Laffy Taffys.
And you guys had them backstage.
-Yeah, we heard.
You like Laffy Taffy so much,
it got to us.
-It made me really care
about you guys.
I cared about you so much
when I walked in here.
-Oh, well, thank you.
That's what we try
to do with our Laffy Taffy,
and I'm glad -- Once again,
Laffy Taffy brings
people together.
And congratulations, guys.
It's really just lovely
meeting you both,
and continued best of luck
on the show.
-Thank you so much
for having us.
-Give it up
for China Anne McClain
and Nafessa Williams, everybody!